那我们还是进入今天继续比较干的话题还是跟价格师本身的一些素养相关对然后比如说刚才我们也讲到就是UIX对吧可能可以在这个话里面去展开聊一下就比如说卡比你这边是怎么去看待各类跨平台的UI框架然后B站这边包括可能也有自己自言的UIX嘛可以大概对我先解释一下对GDEUIX它并不是一个跨屏台的UI框架它目的其实是针对
它其实是compose的一个iOS的一个对应版本也比较对应版本就是一个对齐的这样的一个关系它主要是解决于我们国内的场景不能用SWIFT UI我说实话当然SWIFT UI自己本身也不太稳定它其实还有一些future是不支持的对,UX主要是解决这样的一个问题UX一个设计思想的话其实我刚才在分享过程中列到了它
每一个设计思想其实都可以在安卓的整套技术站里面就是get pack 抨击包这套support cool的里面找到一个对应关系对,它是这样的一个东西然后我前面其实弹幕也看到说关UX会不会去做开源之类的东西我先说一下其实UX它本身是一个非常非常小的一个空下就是它可能就1000行不到对,1000行不到它嘛
在这1000万不到的代码情况下其实它主要是定义了一些包括MEI的饭市一些service的一些定义导出对这样的一些框架型的东西那而且它其实内部是使用到了一些大量的一些地上方的东西对包括依赖注解的这些一些能力其实我自己前面去也说到好用的东西我是不会自己去造的造的一定是一些有价值的或者说特别难的东西所以
目前来看我自己对UX我可能是并不会有一个类似开源的这样的计划我一定是会认为它足够好用了我会输出一些文章让大家去用这套思想去写一个自己的就OK了刚才弹幕我看到说只要1000号牛逼其实不是的因为它基于的是UX很多UX的东西其实不需要我写就这么简单它那种框架形式的东西
就像比如說Github上有很多NVR的一些範石比如阿薩feedback等等很多這樣的一些框架它都是這種前行級的一個代碼框架對背後依賴是什麼背後依賴其實也就依賴了一個DI依賴註解對還有依賴了那個阿薩因為我們航班也不能用航班12個時期也不能用
对就依赖了这两个东西然后然后回到这个问题本身吧就是怎么看待各类的平台优雅框架对然后B站其实用的特别特别多B站什么都有或者说我觉得大多数都用包括Flat也有对比如说B站漫画层对漫画就是用的是Flat然后比如说我们的电商在一起结构其实是天相于那个小程序小程序小游戏的这样的一个模型对然后
我们的pc团队最近pc团队是那个就是其实用b站来也看到有一个比较醒目的那个pc客户端他其实是用的electro对那么其实b站在各类Ui就是跨屏的框架其实用的特别特别多了那我怎么看待这件事情呢其实他其实是好事就是他在我看来跨屏的Ui框架他的最大的特点叫做低上线高下线就是
就是举个例子比如说基于flutter它的包括偏iOS的框架卡不清的就是UI风格偏比如说安卓的那个UI风格那个叫那个material design这类的一些风格室外如果你想扩展自己的东西其实特别特别特别难写但是在这但是这也就意味着它的上限很高就是我们使用的一些
就是已经互联网产品一些通用一些结构下他其实是非常快速的并且他的人力成本投入都特别特别低那么当然他在这个情况下他一定意味着高下限就是他的他的下限很高我不好意思我刚说错了刚才说的是高下限的部分然后我说他低上限的部分低上限这部分是怎么体现的就像虽然我前面在吹比如说跨端或者说全站可能先从外国来看但是我们要思考一件事情
JES的那個環境,就是執行環境,我說他是執行環境,他一定沒有NATIVE的能力那麼強,甚至JES還需要Chrome給他V8,給他加速,他沒有NATIVE我直接去跑裸字接碼的一個上限來搞,這是執行效率來說,那麼我們從更多的一些效率,比如說我之前看,包括嫌疑分享了非常多的一些外界文理等等這樣的一些技術幾個方案。
其實它們本質上來說都是在解決怎麼讓這些跨平台的一些UR框架和Native自己本身去做一個高效的一個結合交互但這也就是它其實那個低上限的一個原因或者說它的低上限投入的成本是更大的那可能甚至需要一個類似偏引擎團隊的這樣的一個組織結構去為它去寫一些plagging啊去寫一些這些東西
对那么没有就是怎么说呢就是这些技术选情他没有一个好坏对就是像B站也特别开放他只有在或者说只有一个底下点就是他在最合适的一个结构情况下使用他最合适的一个技术站就OK了他就这样其实我是不可以理解为现在其实B站业务还是挺好的对对挺好因为我觉得其实呃
在我感觉比如说一个公司对机诱船队的一个整个包括邀请或者说这种选情比较开放的一个状态下肯定是业务非常不错的情况下才会说有这样的一个开放的氛围因为如果说业务相对比较紧张情况下可能会有很多奇迹怪怪的事情发生怎么说这这话分两步来说对就是技术上的开放一定要意味着这件技术能给他业务带来跟他的一个价值嗯必须是这样子就是不然不可能说
對 其實就是manager方面或者說是部門負責人一把手二把手他是不可能放的這樣子來搞的這是一個雙向的一個過程就是你給他信任他給你他的確在你的這個結果就是動作上得到了更快的一個產出結果雙向動輔 對我明白 對所以也就是其實像B站團隊現在是一個非常良性的一個循環的狀態我是這麼理解
对吧 现在处于一个技术和业务在双向很良性的一个循环OK那我真的要提醒大家现在我不知道B站现在还有没有还在抗所以我觉得这个如果真的还有机会的话我觉得B站是一个非常不错的船队从我的角度来说对 那我先插个广告对 关于招聘这一块对 目前B站的话两块吧第一块是偏笑招同学对笑招同学其实是目前B站在
就是非常著重和關注去培養的一個就是人才渠道這是第一個點第二個地方是關於高皮就是因為因為你還看到其實B站的使用了一些技術深度其實還是在這裡的對包括每一個不同的一些團隊其實都是需要一些高皮技術這樣不管是我們的對海外團隊包括我們的就是直播啊然後包括我們的音視片剪輯就是
就是必建的整个团队其实包括我们主战自己本身底层其实都是需要一些就是高批的一些HC的对会有这样的一些HC给到对这样的一些同学可以可以没问题因为我们我们今天直播间我得要当应该有很多高校的同学我们这一期是有高校的渠道的嘛那这些同学其实反正一米加入我们的交流群了嘛然后我们的卡别在交流群里面大家结束之后可以找他单独聊一聊好吧
ok 那我们接着继续往下那关于这个要求这块我觉得我们最后还有一个话题啊那我们就先不聊了就招聘到底看中什么样的我们可以到最后再让我们接聊第七个话题啊就我们怎么去看待各类跨评的语言然后我们是怎么去实践的这个话题我们是不是在刚才第六个问题其实已经讨论过一些了对对对对我这个我就说一个地方就是我自己觉得我自己觉得的话就就
就就一个地方就是我自己也比较期待的就是我一直觉得只要有项目用C++写就他们就一定有读对可能C++这语言太难了基本上C++写出来的都有读那当然我自己可能个人看法是会期待一个就是类似的比较KMM这样对就比如就Cortling那个Cortling Mobile就是Mobile Platform就是跨平台它可以基于KTG写写Maple就甚至类似片
偏头条会用一些Rust去写一些中间层就是公共的一些一些跨端的一些国际代码这样的方式对我觉得这个可能也是一个未来的一个趋势为什么会讲的就是我我想吹一波K的可以可以挺好挺好我觉得就是呃好像所有技术人都对这个东西有一点点比如说是呃不管是底层啊或者是跨端这些东西多多少少他确实就像是那个亚当和
下巴吃的那个对吧是那个苹果吧我就大家都很想去尝一尝就是这个感觉对吧尤其CIA家就不用说了CIA家确实是好像大家所有技术人来说如果有一天我真的能用CIA家写一些东西或者说像Rus这种可能就真的觉得自己可能到了一定的境界好的然后对我我发现我们直播间有一个同学就他一直在问这个问题是那个叫达
摩达辉对他一直在问这个驾驳师的对他说他自己比较结构比较单一嘛他就想成为驾驳师其实我想问一下这个摩达辉就是你目前是在什么状态我们想先了解一下然后我们可以让卡比当地为你分析一下ok就你目前是在什么样的一个呃就是情况就是大概是什么级别啊oc技术大家现在是做oc的一个技术我觉得吧就是嗯怎么说呢就是
假如是也分一些偏业务架构和一些偏底层通用架构两块对然后如果是OC的话我自己先建议的是因为它像是偏IOS几乎战那么一定是先去跟最近的安卓技术战先靠近我之前看到过一篇文章我但我可能就是具体有点忘记了这篇文章是怎么说的呢就是我刚才其实有聊过说
安卓的这套接派克其实他对那个或者他是持续在迭代的他不管他他有support code他从不管v4 v7直接迭代到安卓X然后到接派克他是在不停的嫁入眼镜的但是iOS的基础战或者苹果的基础战直到所谓的UiT开始才有本质上的变化他的UiKit其实是特别特别早而且从来没变的他唯一变化的就是一些新future和一些
比如说把delegate换成block对这种API级别的一些简化那么我给到这位同学的一个建议的话是怎么说呢就莫达会的一个建议叫做说第一你去看安卓怎么去做iOS这些工作举个例子比如说iOS table view的什么delegate data source安卓是怎么用adapter之类的东西来解决的对然后你再去看比如说刚才我说的一些依赖注入
可能蘋果生態的壓力就沒有以來注入那我們去看一些比如說開源生態的一些依賴注入然後對比安卓的Degard filter它是這麼解決的從這條路來看你現在融會貫通你就會發現你可以把LS的一些東西得到就是一些記錄上的一些眼鏡然後可能在你們自己的項目結構裡面對 發生了一個變化這個變化了以後可能對 然後可能你的leader
然后也能得到一个对你的一个正向的一个一个认可然后在逐渐开始去更深入的去看OK比如说嗯怎么说呢但是在是去比如我刚才说的类似国卫API别API的这种模式我们去把业务上的一些问题得到一个解决得到一些信任对然后就逐步吧对这个剩下的一些动作可能对可能这是我的一个小建议吧
明白明白谢谢卡比我觉得应该那个莫达会应该已经知道是大概什么情况了他也在那个直播间发了一条弹幕对我觉得他他应该是离野了到位的台湾的技术思想在不同平台的一个实现过程对好的谢谢卡比那我们再接着往下聊然后我们再讲到就是还是一个逃不过的话题啊就关于单元测试这一块对因为做架构嘛你肯定到最后
还是要考虑整个价格怎么去做合理的测试啊之类的那这一块毕竟这边是怎么实践的我就一个看法这个看法就是说就不要违背人性就是不要去设什么coverage的这种东西不要干这种事对千万不要干这种事我举个反面就毕竟早期干我的事对我们早期在后端因为我们
继续整个构体系是非常容易去自动划生成一些test case对都不需要人手写就发现这东西没有没有任何用一点用都没有因为test case本质上出错的还是小逻辑上的这种然后但是我们后面就把这些case给干掉了但是移动端我也不是不会去要求大家去写test case但是有一些test case会每个研发自己去写或者他一开始不写我跟他说你写一下你只要写一次你就会爱上他
当然这肯定是有一些有些有些模块要求的就比如说为什么要推MVI或者说就是那个基于那个片就是大克斯这样的一个就是单向数据流叫那个unidirectional data flow这样的一个思想它的目的就是为了让你的单元测试非常好写为什么呢因为你只要写过一次你就会发现哇我只要跑过这一次单元测试我甚至都不用去
让起来交付一次测试这种感觉或者这种尝试你只要尝试过一次你得到了甜头你就会刺激了一些就特别特别简单而且像比如说像LS几书这样对比比如说安卓安卓还有GC根本甚至于很多内存问题都不需要考虑LS太容易写出内存泄漏了真的太容易写出内存泄漏了那么一旦你
开始使用的单元测试你会发现我不需要再去加一个那个点应率去log一下我看有没有有没有立刻也不用去用什么因素我只要跑一次pes case我就能判断出结果这件事情怎么说呢就是就是我特别推崇的一个点就是说你你的模块结构你的业务方向结构只要达成了一写单元测试的目就是
條件並且他只要讓研發就是嘗試過一次他就特別特別爽對這其實就是我對單元測試這個點去看法當然我們目前可能怎麼去實踐呢就比如說舉個例子UIX當初寫的時候我們會要求就是所有的測試覆蓋率到100%為什麼呢因為這是對這個框架人自己本身的一種信任感我對他的改動我自己是可控的比如說舉個例子
我举个很常见的例子就是你写一个模块给别人用别人用错了他要来找你对吧找你的时候你会不会心里很烦说哎呀这人怎么这个都不会用啊又来找我但是你又不敢拒绝因为你还真怕就是我的锅导致他雕错了因为你无法看到他是自己蠢还是怎么样出现了异常对那这个时候你你如果说有单元测试你自己跑一遍
你就有很大的一个信心叫做说我没错你自己看完脑去这件事情特别爽对这件事情特别特别爽一旦有这个事情爽爽了之后大家就就喜欢其他一个测试特别是你提供服务越多的人你大约测试觉得越勤快我懂其实关于大约测试确实是因为如果单纯只是要求那个所谓的就是那个覆盖率的话其实是很扯的因为很多单约测试其实可以写的很简单我可能就
其实就是我告诉你这个结果我覆盖但是我具体怎么写这个测试你也不知道你检查不了我这个测试的质量嘛对吧是ok好的行 那我们在啊已经9点半了那看今天我们说一个小时45分钟已经远远超了没关系我们继续聊吧我们把今天所有的这些话题都聊吧我估计大家现在应该也也不是很累因为直播间还有很多同学ok然后我们再讲讲就现在比较比较前沿的东西吧地带码
因为现在其实可能在各个品牌都在讲地带嘛包括讲搭建啊前端可能会特别多对吧应该是前端可能在这个的话题上会聊得比较多对我特别想知道就B站在这边是怎么实践的在移动到这边有没有做一些实践想了解一下这个这个我可能提一点对我理解到暴论对这个这个真的有点粗暴的解释就是我觉得大家很多人用过一些工具吧不管是photoshop或者说是
我把刀臂的全家桶那大家有没有觉得这些工具都是所谓的地带网平台呢对他们他们不就是在界面上给你抽象出各种各种图层各种耗所工具各种这些东西然后让你在那个地方偷偷转转然后他的那个编辑器就是一个运行室环境对然后把这个东西爬了全揉在一起然后出出
做了一个程序出来到中国对那就是这是偏上的一个平台性的层面我们偏下对偏下什么是D代码少写点代码呃那加碼跟C比是不是少写了很多代码对我用HTML跟CSS和我用那个就是传逻辑去写是不是少很多代码嗯对所以在我的看来D代码就是一个扯蛋的事就是造概念的时候
它最多就是叫做说让一些框架型的东西让框架型比如说不管是VUE、Flasher这种级别的东西对可以简化那个叫做说简化运营者或者说使用者的人的门槛就比如说我本来是成冤写的现在我可以让产品写对我甚至后面让运营同学来写对我甚至然后咱再简化比如说很多会从那个
呃就是从设计原型对从飞哥马之类的把导出一套那个结构形态了啊我们就每期因为滴蛋了那不就是个工具吗对所以滴蛋嘛在我看来的话他可能是一个嗯怎么说呢概念性的东西但是他背后的一个背后的一个内涵其实是非常有价值的他都说减化使用者文凯我以后可以不需要成全了对吧这是一个非常
就是我本来要招两个同学我先要招一个设计师我再要招一个什么学我现在我只要招我要招一个什么设计师就OK了对这是我的一个看法好然后但是它的价值就是在于我少了一个人那我必须要做对吧我要做这件事情就是一个低代码好那B站是怎么去实践这件事情的那我们就是让我们思路就是少写代码
怎么少些单呢?举个例子在刚才我说的UIX或者是compose里面它使用比如说KT的DSL Maker然后swift的result builder它使用类似这个样子的一些语言特性去让我代码以前要写以前好现在只要写100号对我们就使用这样的一些手段可以让产品的思想
我本來需要一天時間交付我現在是要一個小時的時間去交付對同樣道理比如說在舉個例子我們有大量的運營活動我們有非常非常大量的運營活動那我們把我們思路就是可能CMS的平台CMS的一個結構對我們把定義的東西就是定義好的一些業務使用到的就比如說運營使用到的一些模板結構我們提前給它
去定型它只需要去做这些级别的托转好那么回到灵回到后面那个极端一个极端我刚才说是偏CMS那另外一个极端就是偏Ending层面的东西就是可以使用托转方式完成那个就是HMLCSS这种级别结构的一个一个托转对在这一个点上我们前端时间是有非常多的对甚至我们还
後面會再做一個就是相當於一個VUE的一個脫債版本就是基於VUE的一個脫債版本但是在那地方我們其實目前是並沒有這樣一個打算的對 大概是這樣我對低代碼的可能的一個定義叫做說第一 你要對低代碼要圈號一個scope它解決的是什麼範圍的一個問題你比如說服務於的是叫做說你一個VUE裡面的運營同學
你千万不要去过渡设计就是你不要去过渡设计程它可以自定义Layout自定义CSS自定义Animation自定义一切不需要它只需要去定义到一个排版就是或者说顺序一个排列顺序就可以了你如果服务于一个是一个程序员结构的东西那你的地带码就是使用更高级的一些语言特径去让大家少写
比如说UNX跟compose就是来解决这样的一个问题对好我基本大概就是这样的一个思路可以可以挺好的OK那时间关系我们先往接着往下走因为现在直播间没有同学在问问题对然后那这应该是到了第二个问题啊就有没有一些提效的开发工具可以推荐这个这个这个其实我本来这个问题想传掉的但是我忘记了
为什么这样子呢?因为我自己是一个,对,我非常推崇工具啊,但是但是我是一个,我是一个,怎么说呢?我不怎么使用工具了,我,我,我,我还是个命令行选手,对,所以我唯一能,对,我唯一能推荐的一些工具就是时间管理工具,对,我还是推荐Notion,对,我推荐Notion的原因,原因还是在于它可以
搜索一些你日常過程中的一些知識積累以及可以管理以上因為我覺得在在互聯網行業很重要的一個問題是你怎麼少被別人反可以專注於解決你自己工作上的一個事兒對這個是我可能唯一能推薦的一個工具然後開發工具我是這麼來看的對因為我我自己傾向於什麼都熟悉自己寫
比如说你今天有需要去review一个result级别的东西因为我们是mode repost结构的我刚才说了有几百个内容便宜compare unit这些compare unit里面就特别多的这些工具比如说一个分析linkmap的工具分析一些尺寸分析一些内存我们会把日常工作中
我記得之前有一個帖子說你只要把這件事你要重複三遍你就把它寫個工具出來我差不多可能就是以這樣的一個思想去給大家推薦就是去寫自己的一個工具那寫工具的過程中其實是對你自己的技術戰也有幫助然後你自己這個工具也當一個產品吧別人用的時候你也很爽明白可以可以好的這期也就用不同的思路了
因为可能比如说我们之前的嘉宾有可能都会推荐一些工具嘛但是可能在卡宇这边有一个不同的观点我们其实也是蛮喜欢的因为我们其实做整个系列活动就希望有不同的听到不同的声音嘛没关系我觉得这个话题还是有收获的Notion嘛大家记住Notion这个应该还是这个我觉得应该是在日常工作中应该算是个管理工具吧对吧它不是一个开发工具OK好的
那我们现在就这个问题吧就刚才也讲到的因为刚才卡比也说我们现在B站其实是有害的抗他的那我们B站招聘这个移动站工程是主要考察哪方面的能力呢嗯对这个我列了几个第一个是我自己觉得就是叫古刀怎么古刀古刀就是就是折腾一件事情的一个能力这个能力据相化一点叫做说找文档
和学习能力对就是有一件事情特别教导说你能提出问题你基本就解决这个问题对那么怎么提出这些问题其实就是你想想怎么去通过找文档的这些方式来锻炼你对那么罗娃可能一个要求是我自己认为英语很重要英语很重要因为我觉得我觉得怎么说呢教导说
至少我觉得我们国内的互联网很基本上问题国外基本都解决过对基本上是我有准说基本上是对所以其实英语能力因为这些文档和这些一些支持回答的这些东西其实还都是在英语上这是我认为的第一个点然后第二个点是这样子的叫做说我自己个人认为
你要有一种把某样东西写到极致的热情对因为我刚才说通用的招聘嘛就是比如说你是一个喜欢写由来的同学你可以代码写的看起来很丑可以看起来很丑我觉得没问题但是你让人写出就是感觉一些细节交互的一些体验对我以前的Lillian说过一些很恶心的话叫做说你写出来的产品要让人有
要填一口的衝動你能寫出這樣子的一個交互級別的東西相當於你對它有極致的一個熱情其實我舉個比戰的一例子比如我們比戰現在有數品視頻它的一個早期方案其實寫的單碼特別特別重但是我覺得很好因為它的交互特別棒我覺得這也是一種我認同
单同的一个结果并不是说代码一定要写的写的特别特别漂亮对第二个点第三个点其实我自己认为就是你要有好奇心对就是好奇心就是设计特别特别广泛就是就是不管是你你有没有想过为什么我在什么一个没有考虑的Activity上它可以展现到屏幕上对
或者说随便下创为什么Sweet UI跟compose是一种偏strike的结果或者说它为什么能是一个要加一个类似一个annotation要composable对有特别多这种这种比如说本档上跟你说你这么喜欢你好奇一下对好奇完了你并且把它积了一下这个对这是我觉得也很重要的一个事然后再有一个点
对就是onel ship对这个onel ship的话就是对就是可能你更了解我觉得对我觉得这个你更有发行权对就是把一件事情你onel下来了把它持续了搞完做完然后并且对它真的能好好教我懂对这个我懂对对可能就这几点吧嗯